hello and welcome very special guest
this is sally lepage hello i'm a
biologist i'm doing my phd at oxford i
am currently in exeter for a conference
um and i also make youtube videos hence
we know each other because just by
having been at oxford together for a
course of about four years we never
actually we never once met uh whilst at
undergrad yeah subscribe to sally which
i'll put a link down here um we are here
to play
thanks to florence schechter yeah who
again you might know from our live
streams we are playing science
pictionary with this lovely artist's
rendering which took hours in photoshop
we have a bowl here of um of um
the science words which our production
assistant behind the counter who does
not have a science who doesn't have a
science degree um has given us we don't
know whether these are going to be right
or even drawable or readable or readable
but we're going to have a minute each in
two rounds so two rounds a minute each
yeah where we are going to try and draw
it and it's a point for every time the
other person gets this correctly yeah so
you win more points if the other person
guesses your drawings and we just have
to be sporting about this and not get
ultra competitive yeah yeah three
two
one
go
oh god we're not allowed any characters
no
atom molecule electron covalent bonding
uh
yeah
oh okay
tardigrade
drostophilia uh hedgehog yes really
that's a science word
uh snail
slug
mollusk yep
oh okay it's my go three two one go
great start
can i blank no
um
all right okay
thank you tv no
cassette tape
oh this is the cell
a nucleus cytoplasm endoplasmic
reticulum rho uh mitochondria
organelle
um
chloroplast
yes he picked up a green pen but i was
wondering how i got that atom
bonds
covalent bonds yes
three
two
one
wave
oh and red blood cells white blood cells
thomas tanken thomas the dank engine
periodic table
um lanthanides actinides
elements yeah
loaf of bread
yeast
wheat
um cereal
oh
what was that carbohydrates oh because i
don't think you would get the
biochemical drawing of it no no
that would be the other way of drawing a
white blood cell
you loving my science word i am loving
the science i think we should keep going
for more than two rounds three two
one go
happy
for me
uh serotonin
exercise
uh
endorphins yes going to say how amazed i
am that i got that
fungus
elephant
anteater
um
lamarckism
origin of species
is
it was meant to be predator i was the
two thoughts i had were either draw a
line or draw the guy from the movie
predator which you haven't seen when you
think of the lion what's the iconic
feature of a lion well it's the main
thing
is that
that was what i was going to do here i
was then going to do a main like that so
that's one
three
two are you ready no one
lot less monster oh um fallopian tubes
vagina
ovaries eggs
no that's not what it is um
sorry um how the hell is he gonna get
this um the lining
um estrogen progesterone
abortion
period period of pain can i pass
no
penis
endometriosis
oh yeah
when the lining of the womb is outside
of the womb
it can only get better from here
well actually having said that i don't
know okay three two one go what is it
with you and putting pens in your mouth
not anymore
reaction yep he gets reaction i get
energy oh my god how am i gonna
i had endometriosis well i didn't have
endometriosis but
torso
lungs
pneumonia
alveoli um
dna
lung cancer
cystic fibrosis
how was i supposed to draw that it was
difficult for you to get that from that
it's not bad actually you know it's
going crazy when there's all these long
related words that you go
dna
moon
crescent
apollo missions
oh oh maybe that's not an s
phases of the moon
um werewolves
lunacycle there we go oh luna no i never
wrote that what's it say lungs
that says luna
definitely luna i'm sorry
go for a real wee one a wee a little wee
one yeah
molecule
body molly oh you're not gonna uh
uh
solar system
that's the sun
atmosphere
oh that's that carbon dioxide yes okay
i was trying to draw the number of
protons i was like that's probably not
gonna help that's not gonna help
yes
why do you need a whole page to draw a
bit from the spur i don't know sally
i'm under pressure here
white um albedo
molecule
oh not lastly symbols
ah
alkane um no
i don't even know what i'm during
anymore
compounds
i think you could have guessed that one
no i don't think i could have that's
actually a pretty hard one that is
really hard
sucks for you doesn't it yeah it does
this is production company i don't think
we should work with them again they are
really mean and hard where did you find
this production company
right so once and for all i don't have a
ball patch in my eyes like food choices
yeah zoom in on these poppers
our production assistant is somewhat new
to
filming
it's taken us so long to get this in
focus we do not want she's hitting the
lights right i have a gap in my eyebrow
through genetics i haven't plucked it i
haven't done anything fancy to it it's
just my dad all right
thank you guys
to my dad
we can move on to my eyebrows please
you're right
i'm trying
one last one minute round in three two
one go
mitosis meiosis yep
boobs breast cancer
nipples one armed woman estrogen
no
cat
pat boob mammary glands mammals yes why
the chemicals no that's milk two minutes
and you're allowed two passes so we
don't get started this is just a finish
finish them off okay are we ready are
you ready two one
a few moments later
again
now so do you want me to redo my boobs
can i just say just to highlight what's
happened the camera stopped filming
nuclear fission mitosis
progesterone that was the uh
contraceptive pill i did get that in the
end yeah we got to this we got to this
but of course we don't know what time
we're on
we don't know what's happening i think
you've done well enough too did i just
get to the end of this one let you guess
guess it i shall have three guesses okay
solar system yes
okay so this is gonna be the last round
yeah i have no idea what the scores are
starting in three two one
are we not starting in three two one we
are starting we're going okay a high
production value strike again
mitochondria yes
i was going to draw a factory next one
lion
someone with curly hair annie
einstein yes einstein
boobs yes
movies to be specific
precipitation
exothermic reaction yes
dot
matrix oh estrogen yes that's not what
contraceptive pill packers look like for
goodness sakes i'm about to take one
penis yes
that was really loud
cell membrane yes
can i just i just can i please slow down
the footage of you with penis
i have no idea who won
um
i'm drained thank you for this
experience ellie you're right thank you
for watching this video thank you sally
for joining me go and subscribe to
sally's channel there's also a video
where i interviewed simon
branching some sharpies at you um where
i interviewed simon about his career and
science communication and youtube and
actual proper stuff
um and sniffing pens and solvent abuse
over on my channel if you want to watch
that um
watch that it was a really good
interview she's very good at it
you're not doing the talking
yeah
why he likes it
bye
thank you thanks everybody oh my god
thanks folks the audience